I
over the past year sports leaks have
been in a frenzy to livestream their
games in virtual reality and mixed
martial arts league Bellator is just the
latest to test out the new tech but
they're taking a slightly different
approach they don't think fans will want
to wear these bulky headsets for an
entire fight I know how I feel about
this like I'm on a boat or something hey
this is crazy I already forgot where I
am outside of this looking at some of
the VR footage out right now that sports
leagues have done is if some of it just
a novelty act a lot of people are
checking the box so to speak just to say
they've done something in VR which is
why you know look we're not actually
covering our fight because we don't at
this point see it as a compelling
experience for people or a compelling
differentiator from what's available
today on their television sets
traditional broadcast cameras are the
pros at covering game footage dozens of
cameramen line the cage and they can get
all the best angles it's hard for this
via our cameraman to compete with that
plus it's not easy to stitch together
footage from six different cameras
that's why Bellator wants to take
viewers somewhere TV can't so you're the
plan is to take these VR camera rigs
into these fighters most intimate
moments and so what makes that
especially unique the reason we're so
excited about this technology and its
application is we're going to take
people to places they can't just buy a
ticket for that's the beauty of it we're
really taking people in a very immersive
and personal way into new places that
they would otherwise not be able to
experience every fight scenario is
different obviously with big fights
there's a little more nerves a little
bit more excitement the adrenaline is
going so you're going to capture all
that in a in a virtual type of reality
that people have never seen you can hear
them stomping their feet you know as I'm
walking out you can hear them chanting
the name and then you'll get the virtual
rerouted the whole arena as they walk
out you want the world to see your your
excitement Your Enthusiasm your emotions
that's what you're going to capture with
this virtual reality you're one of the
pioneers of MMA as a sport and when you
try on something like virtual reality I
mean what do you think about all the
potentials that it could bring and you
know I someone who's seen the sport from
the beginning how do you think this
could shape the sport the range of
emotions that are amazing you know you
see what the strongest man in the world
either broken down crying or celebrating
going to Disneyland you see the wives
children and you see the crowd just
going nuts the corner people have
sacrificed so much and you get to stand
right next to me hem them and be a part
of it but this isn't just about
improving the fan experience many fans
haven't even heard a virtual reality and
most of the headsets haven't hit the
market yet but when they do Bellator
wants to be ready
and how are you making sure that this is
actually going to be a good return on
your investment look it's early days but
in order to be there when it does hit a
mass audience you need to be in it today
he'd be invested in the technology we
have to prove to people that can work
you need to prove to the audience that
it's valuable and when I say valuable
I'm not saying that it's going to
replace what what you're going to see on
television it's going to enhance that
experience it's going to show you a
different angle and what about using
this text to kind of capture the younger
audience maybe that's not already a
super fan are you worried about these
cord cutters are you hoping this hot new
tech can kind of capture some of that
audience as well you know as this
technology emerges and continues to grow
I think that's where we have an
opportunity to really grow in the mass
market I think it will start with the
younger people and I think it'll and
with people who are experimental by
nature and that would then it'll be
championed by them and as it grows then
we're going to be able to start really
seeing a return on the investment so am
I one day going to see an ad pop up in
VR when I watching something I mean
there's a high potential of that I think
you know as I mentioned earlier the
modernization potential is high and I
think it could be just like on a
traditional broadcast today where you're
watching BR and there could be some you
know
some ad integration response to a part
of it right it's like not only are you
going to see this ad you can now walk
through the commercial and experience it
for yourself I would be surprised is
that if that didn't come to fruition